-Performing her platinum hit
"Better Days,"
please welcome Mae Muller!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Oh, no, no ♪
♪ Oh, no, oh ♪
♪ I've been feelin' lonely ♪
♪ I need someone to hold me ♪
♪ Come on, baby, hold me ♪
♪ And oh, I've been feelin'
jaded ♪
♪ Don't know
how I should play it ♪
♪ Tell me how to play it ♪
♪ Now you,
you've been movin' on ♪
♪ Let me know,
can I come along? ♪
♪ Since you're gone,
oh, its been so long ♪
♪ On my own, my own, my own,
my own ♪
♪ Livin' in a haze,
stayin' in the shade ♪
♪ All I do is sit around
and wait for better days ♪
♪ I could use a break ♪
♪ Can I get an "Amen"? ♪
♪ All I do is sit around
and wait for better days ♪
Are we having a good time?
OK!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ I got struck by Cupid,
he got me feeling stupid ♪
♪ How am I 'bout to lose it? ♪
♪ Oh, I'm like
I wanna lay in the sun ♪
♪ Smoke in my lungs ♪
♪ Tying the cherry stem
into a knot with my tongue ♪
♪I know it is dumb but it is
better than none ♪
♪ Now you,
you've been movin' on ♪
♪ Let me know,
can I come along? ♪
♪ Since you're gone,
oh, its been so long ♪
♪ On my own, my own, my own,
my own ♪
♪ Livin' in a haze,
stayin' in the shade ♪
♪ All I do is sit around and
wait for better days ♪
♪ I could use a break,
can I get an "Amen"? ♪
♪ All I do is sit around
and wait for better -- ♪
♪ I sit around, sit around,
sit around and wait ♪
♪ For better, better, better
days ♪
♪ I could use a break ♪
♪ Better, better, better,
better ♪
♪ Better days, oh-oh ♪
♪ No, no
♪No, no ♪
♪ All I do is sit around
and wait for better days ♪
♪ Better days ♪
♪ All I do is sit around and
wait for better days ♪
♪ No, no ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]